It takes the boat 6 hours to go downstream so we know what this corresponding
time must be 6. We know the speed of the boat going downstream is faster with a
current so we'll have the speed of the boat, which is x. And then we'll add the
current which is 12. The return trip for the boat is going to be 8 hours so for
upstream or going against the current we'll have eight for the time. The speed
of the boat against the current will be x minus 12. We'll have the speed of the
boat which is x and then we'll have to subtract off the current speed which is
12. And here's what's different about this problem. We don't know the distances
going upstream or downstream. We'll need expressions for each of these. The
distance is equal to rate times time. So when going upstream the boat's
distance would be x minus 12, the rate times 8, the time. And when going
downstream we'll have the rate x plus 12 times the time which is 6. This is our
complete table with all the information we need. And if we want we go ahead and
simplify each of these expressions. When we distribute the eight, we'll have 8x
minus 96 for the first one. And we distribute the six, we'll have 6x plus 72
here.